[Musique]
vous avez cru que c'était la fin mais en
fait c'était le début bonsoir bienvenue
dans le grand studio du figaro on est
avec vous on est en direct c'est figaro
live et on attend vos points de vue sur
ce voilà qui enflamme la toile ce voile
qui enflamme également le débat se voile
islamique
oubliez semble-t-il de la loi sur la
séparation le séparatisme censé lutter
contre le séparatisme islamistes la loi
sur les principes républicains c'est en
tout cas l'avis du groupe
lr à l'assemblée est ce celui de laurent
joffrin et bien vous pouvez lui poser la
question parce qu'il est là justement en
plateau ce soir bonsoir laurent
fondateur des invalides sens et où cet
ancien directeur de libération
maintenant parce que c'était une saison
va y revenir
est ce que je peux répondre à la
question après avoir fait la
présentation et surtout vous ne pouvez
pas vous faire le dernier numéro du
figaro magazine qui est consacré à un
sujet qui vous est cher j'ai vu comptait
cinq livres sur napoléon dont trois
romans absolument et il y en a qui
s'appelle le grand complot doit faire
face à vous c'est le complot de cadoudal
c'est quand l'autre est vrai gala mais
ce serait intéressant d'avoir un autre
débat à jour d'ailleurs sur 7 toute
cette question bordeaux face à vous
quelqu'un vraiment pour débattre avec
vous ivan rioufol chroniqueur au figaro
bonsoir yvan est propriétaire d'un
compte twitter quand il n'est pas
censuré parce que quand les postes
envoyés sur twitter ne déplace pas trop
aux maîtres censeurs de la côte ouest
californienne quand ça ne concerne pas
les drones faut que ça concerne pas le
séparatisme islamistes l'hydroxyde
chloroquine quoi d'autre encore je ne
sais pas ça m'a un peu échappé chirurgie
et et j'étais enfin vos posts aussi nous
ont échappé la sonde a pu les lire du
coup un bon décidé de cadrer un peu une
fois ils ont sans cesse et donc vous
êtes du côté des maîtres censeurs ils
vont verser pas le débat de ce soir
sachant que on y reviendra peut-être
dans les prochains jours il ya un
sénateur
récemment l air qui a été qui a été
censuré également des militante lgbt
donc c'est une vraie question qui est
posée sur les réseaux sociaux il ya une
autre question qui est posée c'est si la
france est une démocratie défaillante
alors c'est pas en lien avec ce qui
arrive à yvan mais sait on ce qu'on se
demande a directement puisque cela
concerne justement l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et en dix ans le dernier
classement ou des classements plus
exactement du rapport annuel sur les
démocraties établies par les d'ozil
économistes des deux britanniques
eh bien on voit que la france est
devenue est classé comme démocratie
défaillante
alors est-ce un vrai warning ou encore
une perfidie d'albion parce qu'on
rappelle encore une fois que j'y
économistes et britanniques
j'attends vos réponses j'attends vos
points de vue mais d'abord donc la
polémique de ces dernières heures
l'angle mort de la loi de 2004 en tous
les cas selon les députés aient l'air
l'interdiction du voile à la fac et dans
les sorties scolaires en tout cas ce
n'est pas encore le cas et c'est le
nouveau cheval de bataille
députés républicains dans le débat sur
la loi je le répète censé lutter contre
le séparatisme et pourquoi je dis censé
lutter contre le séparatisme c'était une
loi qui était promis en ces termes dans
le discours d' emmanuel macron aux
mureaux après la mort de samuel paty et
qui finalement s'appelle la loi
protégeant les principes sur les
principes républicains
en attendant de débattre peut-être
éventuellement sur le sens et où pas
sensé je vous propose d'écouter donc
justement la sortie d'eric ciotti député
des alpes-maritimes sur cette affaire
cette nouvelle affaire du voile
islamique
ce voile incarne tout au contraire cet
asservissement cet obscurantisme le fait
que la femme n'est représenté n'est pas
incarné uniquement comme un moule en
objet de tentations qu'il conviendrait
de dissimuler et bien cet obscurantisme
n'a plus sa place et notamment dans les
salles de coûts il faut aujourd'hui
érigé des garde-fous il faut ériger des
digues
eh bien le seul qui n'a pas été entendu
puisque l'amendement qu'ils proposent a
été rejetée et il rejetées avec vigueur
par la gauche d'abord dans la majorité
avec le député poidevin sache à oublier
donc le voile comme une obsession pour
les républicains
votre contre-projet le voile votre
réforme constitutionnelle le voile autre
solution pour la société le voile votre
lutte contre le séparatisme le voile c
est à la fois grossier stigmatisant
inutile bref finalement ça n'a que peu
d'intérêt
et vous avez la levée de boucliers
version insoumise avec le député eric
coquerel député de seine-saint-denis
savez vous que le voile d'une mariée
chrétienne signifie le fait qu' il y à
une soumission de la femme à son époux
est ce que vous allez demander
dorénavant au nom de ce que vous portez
il vient évidemment c'est exactement ça
c'est exactement ça exactement comme les
religieuses relisez les textes est ce
que au nom de cette revendication
vous allez demander dorénavant que les
mariages religieux ne se fasse plus de
la même manière
laurent vous autre côté ou un saut mieux
coté à l'om dans cette affaire celui là
je vais pas souvent d'accord avec un son
beaucoup de sujets mais sur celui là il
n'ya pas de doute la question de
l'interdiction du voile dans l'espace
public était une folie a été écarté au
moment de la loi de 1905 il y avait eu
il y avait eu des députés laïque un peu
extrême qui avait proposé d'interdire
les soutanes le rapporteur bryant et son
adjoint jean jaurès excusez du peu
on dit mais non on va pas interdire ce
genre de choses il y avait deux raisons
la première c'est que la police a quand
même mieux à faire que de courir après
des gens qui sont en soutane ou
aujourd'hui les femmes qui portent le
voile
premier point est le deuxième point le
disent et ils les catholiques trouveront
toujours un autre moyen vestimentaire
pour manifester leur appartenance
religieuse dans l'espace public
à partir de là c'est exact on est dans
la même situation c'est à dire que on
décrète que le voile est imposé à toutes
les femmes musulmanes ce qui n'est pas
vrai ce qui est vrai d'une partie
d'entre elles mais pas de l'autre et
darmanin un bon exemple
regardez la dame qui fait campagne
contre l'islamisme et qui est par
ailleurs la mère d'un policier musulman
qui a été tué nathan hines est elle est
voilée on va lui interdire ces véhicules
alors comme ça c'est ridicule là
l'air s'est concentré sur les mers qui
accompagnent les enfants dans les
sorties scolaires et sur l'université
c'est un peu compliqué sur les sorties
scolaires il ya eu de multiples
jugements qui ont dit mais non c'est pas
une mission de service public ça
consiste à aider un peu les professeurs
mais c'est pas une tâche d'enseignement
donc il ya pas de raison d'interdire le
voile puisqu'il est interdit à l'école
mais pas à l'extérieur
premier point quant à l'université le à
l'université on a le droit de manifester
sa son appartenance religieuse qui est
pas le cas dans le secondaire à
l'université c'est déjà le cas si vous
interdisez le voile à l'université faut
interdire la kippa vous n'y a pas de
raison où il faut interdire les signes
catholique ostensible moi quand j'étais
étudiant il y avait parfois des prêtres
qui étaient des cons des condisciples
des lettres comment étudiants comme moi
on va interdire aux prêtres de venir en
nombre en soutane mais en col romain en
col romain donc c'est tout ça est une
obsession c'est pour marquer des points
politiques parce que il ya une partie de
l'opinion qui est très hostile à l'islam
en général ça correspond en fait je
parle trop non pas du tout c'est
intéressant on va bien avoir la réponse
pour une fois que je parle qui ne
parlent pas en profite mais on va te
donner la parole des plus le monde qui
peuvent les x-men certains parlent mais
je répondrais oui et après on verra
peut-être sur la stratégie à l'air dans
dés que vous et que vous croyez que vous
décrypter en tous les cas derrière 700
cd replay que vous êtes censés décrypter
non vous allez la décrypter en
fonctionnel vous allez nous donner votre
décryptage actes et plus exactement
votre point de vue mais on va demander
d'abord celui d'yvon laurent joffrin est
un faux naïf parce qu'il nous laisse
croire que le voile islamique serait
serait comparable à la soutane du curé
ça n'a absolument rien à voir et
d'ailleurs mais en fait je ne lui en
veux pas trop parce que ce problème est
mal posé il a été posée en terme de
laïcité et les religions hésiter circuit
dit que ça n'a rien à voir le sous la
soutane émeraude islamique est déjà
parce que là le
la soutane est un engagement religieux
qui presque une profession il que le
voile islamique vous n'avez pas besoin
non plus dans un engagement religieux
sunnite si je me suis la soutane c'est
quelqu'un qui est dans un clergé ce qui
n'est pas forcément le cas bien sûr mais
au delà de tout ça on a bien compris que
si l'on parlait du voile à propos du
séparatisme c'est que le séparatisme se
voit à travers le voile aujourd'hui et
le voile n'est pas un symbole religieux
contrairement ce que vous laissez croire
c'est un symbole politique c'est un
symbole d'un séparatisme c'est un
symbole d'une adhésion à une idéologie à
une idéologie non pas musulmane est mais
en tout cas à ce qui est et ce qui est
la conséquence de cette idéologie
musulmanes à travers son application
théorique politique dogmatique qui est
celle d'appliquer la charia comme une
sorte de nouvelle constitution
donc le voile est un refus de vivre avec
nous c'est un refus de notre société
c'est un séparatisme affichée et c'est
une adhésion à un dogme de mon point de
vue totalitaire c'est à nîmes cet islam
intégriste que l'on peut considérer
comme étant en effet une part ça ça son
envergure éparses à la propension
qu'elle a à vouloir tout régime monte de
la vie privée de tout le monde comme
étant en effet une doctrine totalitaire
totalisante total d'appeler la comme
vous voulez mais en tout cas une
doctrine dangereuse et donc le problème
qui est posé aujourd'hui est de vouloir
se payer de se confronter non pas un
voile comme étant un anneau d'un signe
religieux ou naturellement la jourre
joindrait pas ce qu'on n'apprendra pas y
mettre notre nez bien sûr c'est de la
liberté tout le monde que deux ports de
d'être de voir ça dans la région qui le
met d'avoir à se confronter à cette
nouvelle contre société qui est en train
de fracturer l'unité de la nation et
keith euros et qui se retrouve à travers
cet uniforme l' or si vous ne voulez pas
voir que c'est un uniforme
vous ne pourrez pas lutter contre 7
contre société qui j'imagine vous
révulse autant que moi donc je vois chez
vous une contradiction une faiblesse une
naïveté une fausse naïveté parce que je
ne voulais pas naïf et je trouve que
vous ne donnez pas jouer vous reflétez
précisément la grande paresse
intellectuelle peut-être la grande
faiblesse la grande peur dans le fond à
vouloir affronter ce qu'est ce
totalitarisme à la alors puisque des
attaques directes sur la paresse
intellectuelle de laurent joffrin a
laissé une merveille je suis prêt aussi
par sp plus barrés brio folle en tout
cas vous permettre de répondre pourquoi
vous dites que le problème est mal posé
juste y vivent encore une fois le
problème devrait être posée d'un point
de vue strictement politique sont nous
sommes face à une fronde mme en
politique face à une guerre politique
face à une guerre de civilisation et
donc de mettre ce sujet sur le thème de
la laïcité et de la religion cela cela
nous hambourg dans des débats qui
n'auront pas de fin et surtout des
débats qui seront dès à présent à nous
guider dans la mesure où effectivement
chacun a droit de bien revendiquer ce
rang dirigeants il ya un point sur
lequel je pourrais éventuellement
peut-être rejoindre rioufol c'est la
question de l'idéologie ce avec l'islam
politique salafisme le l'idéologie des
frères musulmans
ce sont des idéologies politiques
dangereuses nuisibles qu'il faut
combattre ça on est d'accord mais je
voudrais rappeler que dans l'histoire de
france il ya eu parmi d'autres une
idéologie qui se rattachent et un régime
totalité à café l'union soviétique on
n'a jamais interdit le parti communiste
on a interdit pendant la guerre mais en
dehors des guerres et les signes
ostensibles d'appartenance aux
communistes étaient légaux drogue serait
qu'un drapeau rouge avec une effigie de
lénine même de staline et on avait le
droit de dents brigade est la genèse
dans les jeunesses communistes
tout ça était légale or ça se rattacher
un pays et une allégeance même du parti
comme le parti communiste n'est ni à
droite ni à gauche mais oui c'est guy
voilà qui avait dit cela il avait raison
mais on ne va pas interdit donc je
trouve que c'est un moyen autant le
l'islamisme est nuisible
autant les moyens de lutter contre lui
ne sont pas forcément tous les plus
intelligents les plus efficaces parce
que le voile c'est pour partie des
musulmans intégrés c'est un symptôme
donc il faut lutter contre comtois aussi
contre les racines du mal si je publiais
donc vous pouvez le faire par exemple
sur les prêches haineux ou intolérants
dans les mosquées où c'est interdit mais
je le fais je pose une question ils ont
je voudrais quand même préciser parce
que je ne veux pas interdire l'islam
isme je suis un libéral et j'ai été de
ceux ici même d'ailleurs qui avait dit
qu'il était inutile de dissoudre le cci
c'est pour vous dire que le libéralisme
n'a été alors justement premières vont
jusqu'à l'expression mais votre allergie
aux voiles parce que mon allergie aux
voix parce que parce que je pense que le
voile est un était précisément ce qui se
voit le plus est qui et qui est vécu
comme une sorte de défi à notre société
et si vous acceptez ce défi là vous
acceptez les autres noms en travers le
vin du tout mais que l'on voit
maintenant c'est interdit à l'école
est-ce que l'on interdise que ce que
l'on voit apparaître maintenant à
travers les universités où le voile est
permis par deux jeunes femmes c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y avait des
témoignages qui arrive aujourd'hui
qu'ils vous disent que c'est une femme
maintenant elle porte le voile veut le
faire également les prières dans les
universités et quoi demain encore
d'autres dont il n'a pas oublié bien oui
à tout messi mais je préfère le mal je
pense qu'ils l'ont interrogé c'est
l'argument j'ai lu et l'engrenage si je
sais que l'argument de l'engrenage est
un très bon argument
pourquoi laisser s'égrener n'est jamais
automatique vous donnez un acte de
faiblesse vous direct de faiblesse en
acceptant cet acte revendicatif d'un
uniforme totalitaire de mon point de vue
qui en suit donne prétexte pour celle
qu'il porte à vouloir et exiger des
prières à vouloir exiger demain des
d'avoir des débats différents de ceux
qui ne sont pas dans leur religion etc
etc
donc je trouve que c'est très dangereux
et cela affaiblit cela manifeste de
notre affaiblissement
mais en même temps le débat est tout à
fait et compliqué je ne dis pas qu'ils
je ne dis pas que ce serait simple que
de que d'interdire le voile mais moi je
milite pour être très clair en tout cas
pour l'interdiction du voile à
l'université dans les lieux publics
et bien sûr un accompagnement scolaire
en accompagnement scolaire bien entendu
en vue en priorité mais là le une
question pour l'homme de gauche que vous
n'êtes pas du grand donc attaché à la
cause féministe le voile islamiste est
un signe de soumission de la femme aux
hommes et c'est vrai oui va en général
pas toujours toujours me faire en
général oui d'ailleurs dans les pays
musulmans le le port le port du voile a
accompagné ou à manifester les gains
progressifs politique de l'islam
politique est dur culpabilité
intelligemment
mais si vous interdisez le voile à
l'université il faut interdire la kippa
vous pouvez pas fait autrement n'y a pas
d'endroit où et pas par exemple six
blessés selon les jours si vous faut
interdire avant pendant ou pose juste la
question pour aller jusqu'au bout chou
blanc sur la langue sous l'angle
féministe et s la kippa n'est pas un
signe de soumission des femmes et hommes
ça peut se discuter et les offres qu'ils
portent pas les lacroix appareil il
n'est pas une solution mais croyez moi
je connais je sais aussi bien des hommes
que les femmes
c'est pour ça que je connais des
familles juives très très pratiquants et
pieuse où les femmes sont tondus elles
ont une perruque
vous allez interdire ça ça n'a pas de
sens c'est pour ces temps ci on danse
est un signe de soumission ne peut pas
dépenser en place ce débat sur le thème
panahi site et on ne s'en sort pas parce
qu'effectivement les arguments de jeu
françois tout à fait recevable si vous
interdisez au nom de la laïcité des port
ostensible où les interdisait tout alors
je n'en sort pas donc juste quelle
rubrique voulait mettre ça sur l'afrique
sur la rubrique d'une déstabilisation
politique
c'est un axe et encore une fois c'est un
drap vous le voyez où ça nous mène ça
nous mêmes alors écoutez toute
organisation interdite on interdit bien
les manifestations fasciste je trouve
que cet islamisme on a un gros match et
on a interdit les ligues fascistes parce
que oui il ya eu le 6 février 34 ou
c'est extrêmement violent et bien alors
là et les décapitations ça vous suffit
pas il en photo mais ça c'est les
terroristes islamiques lui bien
exactement frères musulmans heureusement
son pater féroé cette idéologie cctv
tellement dangereux qui vous détestent
qui nous avaient du mal à comprendre
non j'ai joué parfaitement je pense que
dans l'état de droit vous pouvez
interdire aux gens des choses qui font
pas des choses qui pense aux gens de
penser mal c'est pas possible c'est
parce que je sors les frères musulmans
c'est parce que je sens une fois la
forme oui mais c'est d'abord c'est pas
un uniforme allemand on a fait des
enquêtes quand j'étais arrivé plusieurs
fois sur les jeunes femmes voilées il
faut reparler vous allez la moitié au
moins les trois quarts qu'ils disent
mais non c'est ça correspond à mes
convictions j'ai pas été obligé de faire
ça donc l'appartement qu'avait aussi
visibles sont obligés de remercie les
prouver qu'elles sont obligées c'est
autre chose mais c'est rare oui il
existe qui est un embrigadement terril
de ces jeunes femmes leur mère n'était
pas voilée leurs moeurs était même
contente de se dévoiler vous voyez bien
que les femmes d'iraniens et comment
voulez-vous que j'adore
oui c'est raconter mais je ne sais pas
si je ne dis pas que c'est pas parce qu
on réprouve une idéologie
automatiquement l'intervalle on est en
démocratie mais vous avez tort et que
j'ai raison je vais jetter c'est très
compliqué et en même temps je pense que
si l'on ne voit pas quel est le danger
qu'ils représentent est par cette
revendication d'un voile comme un acte
de jeu voit très bien dans l'acte
politique t2c par équipe et si on ne
peut pas y répondre on ne répondra à
rien d'autre et donc je pense qu'on est
dans cet engrenage célébration à
laquelle il faut aujourd'hui répondre
d'une manière très très brutal très
cruel peut-être même d'ailleurs
et parfois c'est entre nous une manière
pratique
les policiers ont mieux à faire courir
après les femmes des blés et nos grands
et d'autre part je le problème est mal
posé vous voyez une intervention
policière dans le final pour excuser les
femmes voilées j'ai une question vous
j'ai une question juste à vous poser
finalement depuis creil depuis la sphère
de creil depuis 1981 1989 90 ans au lieu
de 89
donc si je parle au moins de 20 ans on à
l'époque où il ya deux collégiennes dans
un dans un collège de trois collégiennes
dans un voyage de creil qui arrive
voilée est le principal dont le
directeur du collège et des fromages of
refus formations de gauche refuse
justement parce que c'est une atteinte à
la laïcité qu'elle
qu'elle vienne au collège et ce débat va
diviser profondément la gauche et la
droite également mais quand même on a
trouvé un point d'équilibré et de loi
qui a été passé à la fin des phases et
loi qui dit bon dans les salles de
classe non depuis les autorités
musulmanes reconnu on dit mme on n'est
pas d'accord mais on accepte et seul qui
n'accepte pas c'est les groupes n'est
pas dire raison pardon vous donnez pas
vous n'êtes pas de donner raison aux
raisonnements divan en disant ça pardon
bien parce que dans les salles de classe
l'enseignement est neutre il n'ya pas
d'un prosélytisme ya pas de produits
interdits à l'université c'est différent
parce que les gens seulement dieu cité
c'est pas différent c'est pas ils sont
adultes mais aussi parce qu'on ne sait
pas différent s'est désolé mais quand on
est à l'école art général des mineurs à
l'université en général on est majeur et
bien que vous a fait une bagarre entre
votre raisonnement vous acceptez la
l'interdiction du voile effectivement à
l'école et vous avez bien raison et vous
le refusez à la à l'université alors que
la maturité n'est pas du tout la même ça
peut tout au moins se discuter mais
aussi celle là non la même chose que
vous reconnaissez que dans un cas le
voile est un asservissement et un acte
politique dans l'aude une retenue ans et
plus dont acte de prosélytisme politique
dans une manade des classes moyennes on
vous manipuler ou bien me laisse mon ami
elle est née elle de la gauche mais je
voudrais aller un peu plus loin parce
que ce débat est également mal posée
parce que je pense que dans le fond ce
ne sont pas les islamistes qu'ils sont
en tort
ce sont les politiques c'est notre
propre collectivité si je veux dire
c'est à dire que depuis maintenant 30
ans 40 ans d le la pensée commune
inspirée très largement par par le
progressisme leur présente joffrin a
décidé que l'assimilation n'avait plus
lieu d'être l'assimilation c'était donc
de 7,7 up ce parcours obligé qui on
demandait à l'étranger de ceux de se
débarrasser de tout son passé
c'était d'ailleurs un peu brute table
que l'assimilation d'alépé lieu d'être
il fallait aujourd'hui aller vers
l'inclusion c'est à dire c'était le
thème développé par terra nova le think
tank socialiste il y a dix ans de cela
et l'inclusion a créé cette société
multiculturelle dans laquelle qui permet
aujourd'hui précisément à toutes les
minorités à toutes les minorités de
de venir en france comme elles sont
c'est à dire sans faire aucun effort
d'intégration et donc je ne fais pas du
tout grief à ces jeunes femmes
si l'on parle de cela toujours de porter
le voile je fait grief à la république
d'avoir abandonné ce sont pour le modèle
assimilationniste pour un modèle
multicoques multiculturelle laurent vous
répondez à prendre à rêver aux
internautes le on peut plus demander aux
gens d'être renoncer totalement à ce
qu'ils sont c'est bon peut-être que ça a
été le cas dit qu il soit vérifiée mais
historiquement c'est peut-être c'était
le cas au début de la république on
disait il fallait tout le monde doit
être au carré depuis maintenant 40 ans
50 ans il ya une tolérance sur les
différences plus grande qu'avant je le
reconnai volontier mais il ya des
limites mais dire qu'il ya pas de limite
non si les lions il ya bien des limites
il ya des limites qui sera de la fête il
ya d'abord il ya les limites des lois
quand même respecter la loi et
deuxièmement il ya une culture
républicaine qui tend à dominer quand
même que les gens et là c'est pas de la
blague je vais terminer le faisait
parler le mans laurent vous terminez
non non non non vous terminez wii ne le
sait on ne peut pas obliger les gens à
quitter leur identité voilà qui respecte
un les lois deuxièmement que la culture
attendait jeta mail j'ai retrouvé mon
fils dès lors quelle culture
républicaine domine ce quelqu'un regarde
et je suis pas si vous en avez beaucoup
parlé au figaro je crois qu'a eu des
papiers sur la charte qu elle consignait
les principales organisations musulmanes
oui vous lisez à 3 qu'on en passe au
pilon pas si oui tout en dit toujours il
ya trois sélections
oui c'est les turcs oui tous les autres
jeux six associations turques et une
association de guillon lundi on va
vérifier le transit si c'est le cas les
autres ont signé les autres sont les
principales le dire or vous lisez cette
charte
elle correspond à mon avis est ce que
pensent ils mangent majorité des
musulmans en france
donc ces musulmans qui pratiquent une
religion qui peuvent même dans certains
cas porter des vêtements reconnaissable
mais d'une autre mais ces gens là sont
d'accord avec ça parce que ça les
protège si moi je la laïcité ça protège
vers les gens juste une dernière réponse
yvan mais vraiment ce que sinon on va
pas pouvoir faire de zèle en débat et je
sais que je suis face on joue on vous
réconciliera pas donc juste cours
brièvement - jeu jusqu'au bout je dis
que quand vous mettez le doigt dans
l'engrenage du communautarisme brooklyn
est là vous allez vers le comique vers
le multiculturalisme obligatoirement et
donc et d'autre et et bibi je m'arrête
là si on est vraiment si on est pris de
court mais fort donc ce mépris du coup
on n'a pas pris de court mme alfort on a
compris que lord a quand même pris vos
points de vue qu'ils sont
pas exactement sur pas exactement les
mêmes ce n'est pas un oubli mais un
recul du gouvernement nous dit mélomanes
à propos de la loi sur la tabulation
séparatisme islamistes oui clairement il
faut faire un focus me dit kris kross
sur le voile islamique
kriss kross qui vous suggère d'ailleurs
de quitter twitter mais savons c'est un
autre débat au fond le problème n'est
pas le maître vêtements mais l'idéologie
qu'ils portent dit ricco comme le dit
yvan on ne vais pas combattre réellement
l'islamisme déplore chardon bleu cet
internaute encore nous laisser une place
trop importante au débat autour du voile
c'est dangereux
nicole estime qu'il faut interdire le
voile partout nous sommes pas un pays
musulman omnium pense comme vous et
comme notre ami
coquerel pour les relier pour les
religieuses le voile est en quelque
sorte un vêtement de travail va t'on les
interdire aussi et sept autres à nos
internautes qui nous dit que rioufol a
le mérite de dire des choses est l
inverse cet internaute qui nous dit sur
word sur youtube qui défend un peu la
thèse que vous défendrez dans votre
dernière dans leur dernière lettre
laurent on essaie de faire diversion
avec l'islam pour faire oublier le
chômage chardons bleus encore ce voile
est un effet est un cheval de troie si
la france fasse interdit le voile nous
dit à des ailes de l inverse elle va se
ridiculiser dans les pays occidentaux au
frais à ces femmes voilées des
connaissances épanouissante durant le
cursus scolaire vous verrez elles ne
seront plus tentés de se voiler françois
nous dit des décennies qu'on parle du
voile en france où toutes les cultures
couture il n'y a pas d'autres sujets
plus prioritaires et vient tous les cars
ont posé la question sur twitter le
voile islamique et il le grand oublié du
projet de loi contre le séparatisme et
ceux qui nous ont répondu en tous les
cas répondre oui à 73% juste un tout
petit mot sur une des interventions qui
est très intéressante
la dame dit il faut interdire le voile
on n'est pas un pays musulman mais c'est
toute la question est ce qu'on est un
pays qui va accepter un islam
reste respectueux des lois et français
ou est ce qu'on refuse que la france ait
séché l étape ils forment une forte
minorité musulmane c'est le fond de la
faire ah ben oui mais si le fond
d'affaires du tout je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous mais je moi je pense
ma conviction est que je pense qu'on
peut assimiler l'islam c'est l'islam se
réduit à ou cinq piliers de l'islam mais
que l'islam et inassimilable s'il se
revendique de la charia or dans la
chartre des imams vous remarquerez que
les imams ne renonce pas à la charia ne
renonce pas non plus au jihad
donc la chartre est en fait très
insuffisant je vous propose de faire un
débat sur la charte mais qu'on avait
déjà fait déjà fait déjà un premier
débat est un réflexe mais on y repère
parce qu'on y reviendra
on y reviendra il y reviendra beaucoup
de choses qui n'y sont pas on y
reviendra pas ce que ça vaut un débat en
soi il ya une autre question
effectivement qu'on a soulevé il nous
reste plus tellement de temps mais on va
en prendre un petit peu
c'est cet index de la démocratie global
qui est établi par the economist que
j'ai découvert l'a récemment et qui
classe ou plus exactement des classes la
france la france serait moins
démocratique que l'espagne le canada
l'allemagne ou un pays cher à laurent
joffrin la nouvelle zélande
c'est donc en tout cas ce qui ressort de
cet index mondial établi par le par
l'hebdomadaire britannique et qui écrit
déconfinement sévères et des couvre feux
nationaux ont conduit à une légère mais
signification significative diminution
pardon de son score global on se dit on
a l'impression que c'est vous qui l'avez
écrivant ce cette phrase ce texte mais
en fin de set écrit dans nos économies
il ne s'agit pas d etienne a qu'à la
ministre ça ne surprend pas mais cette
crise de la démocratie elle ne date pas
de la crise du coc vide je sais crise de
la démocratie c'est-à-dire cette sous
représentation du tout une partie d'une
opinion qui ne se représente il se
retrouve plus dans l'assiette démocratie
représentative
elle date au moins à tout le moins de
2005 et du référendum sur la boue savez
sur la constitution européenne qui avait
été réécrit terreux et réinstallés dans
le dos des français en 2007 travers le
traité de lisbonne clyde il y avait déjà
eu de la première trahison démocratique
et depuis
pour aller vite en effet je pense que la
crise du coc vide tout accentué dans
l'indifférence d'ailleurs de beaucoup de
médias d'abord elle a naturellement est
là à porter atteinte à nos propres
libertés nous propre liberté d'aller et
venir d'entreprendre la liberté
également de pratiquer son culte la
liberté pour les praticiens pour les
médecins de pratiquer leur médecine etc
donc il ya eu quand même des atteintes
graves à la liberté et surtout et plus
grave encore je pense que les
contre-pouvoirs n'ont pas fait non plus
fonctionné c'est à dire que nous sommes
maintenant en état d'urgence renouvelé
depuis maintenant un an de l'état
d'urgence a été renouvelée je crois de
plus jusqu'en juin c'est à dire que le
parlement le
l'assemblée nationale comme le sénat ne
servent plus à rien les décisions ne
sont même plus prises en conseil des
ministres mais dans un conseil
scientifique restreint qui ne fait qu il
ne donne qu en cas d experts nos élus et
l'on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui le
président de la république a pris
l'ensemble des pouvoirs que pouvait lui
donner la vème république dans une sorte
de super présent des de
présidentialisation qui est avec un plus
une sorte de pente d'autorité et de
l'autoroute autoritarisme que j'avais
décrit dès le départ chez ce personnage
qui fait qui me fait dire que macron
n'est certainement pas le premier à
pouvoir donner des leçons de démocratie
aussi à ce qu'il appelle les démocraties
libérales des pays des pays de l'est
voilà en quelques mots
laurent qu'est ce que justement l'ancien
journaliste est maintenant devenu acteur
politique
on se dit quand ils voient cet index est
ce que vous verrez c'est logique
est ce que vous êtes d'accord ou est-ce
que vous voyez une limite du rapport et
alinéa l'upa l'acceptabilité des mesures
par les populations et est-ce que
l'ajustement c'est pas une limite au
sida mais l'embellie gens quand on a
accepté la servette une servitude
volontaire
l'acceptation n'est pas le seul critère
le si on résume un gros à grands traits
les démocraties ont le droit sans
contredire leur nature de prendre des
mesures d'exception
on a le droit de faire ça c'est même
dans la constitution en faire entendre
guerre ont réduit les libertés publiques
en temps de pandémie on peut prendre des
mesures qui sont restrictives de liberté
publique c'est vrai mais là où c'est là
où le l'économiste n'a pas tout à fait
tort c'est que logiquement on doit en
référer autant que possible et le plus
possible au parlement déjà le parlement
de discuter des mesures que ce soit
débattue publiquement et que ce soit
critiquée dans l'ain dans l'enceinte de
la représentation nationale
et deuxièmement les organes
gouvernementaux gouvernementaux doivent
fonctionner à peu près normalement
en période de guerre il ya un cabinet de
guerre qui prend une sorte de décision
même en grande bretagne est l'exemple
même de la démocratie représentative et
respectueuse liberté pendant la guerre
churchill avait pratiquement tous les
pouvoirs et s'était entendue comme ça et
c'était logique puisqu'il y avait une
question de vie ou de mort ce qui est
sous une forme atténuée un peu le camp
une phase de pandémie view de mal donc
mais c'est vrai que la france a une
tendance à la centralisation des
pouvoirs à faire jouer les mécanismes
monarchie républicaine qui est très
contestable
ça c'est vrai et je pense que là dessus
alors pour qu'elle ne nuise à raison qui
est un journal libéral en économie ce
que je réprouve plus tôt mais quel agent
à libéral en politique puisque je tends
approuvait la démocratie vous object
philippe sur youtube n'a rien à voir
avec la gestion de la crise les gens
pourront toujours voter pour un autre
candidat en 2022 et bien pas pour
l'instant on parle de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui bien sûr je pense que les
lits pourrait y avoir effectivement une
sorte de réaction populaire
nous l'avons déjà vu à l'oeuvre il ya
deux ans cela démontre assez pas
complètement défaillante
il enlevait faire ça dans une personne
ne dit que nous sommes en dictature 20
on peut être on peut soutenir que nous
sommes en dictature sanitaires sont
vraiment envie de grossir le trait mais
en tout cas encore un dieu merci on est
on peut encore en lice sommes là à
discuter et il vous faire bannir et il
ya personne qui va nous attendre à la
sortie pour nous pour nous envoyer au
cabanon va je l'espère même si j'ai été
censuré effectivement sur twitter ce qui
connaît ma mais ici je me mettrai en
travers sur vous mais je n'en doute pas
là dessus on peut se trouver mais mais
notre liberté il faut faire très
attention justement à la réaction
populaire parce que ce sont ces gens là
qui essaient c'est le peuple français
c'est la démocratie qui pour l'instant
qui est bâillonnée c'est le cas de le
dire très symboliquement avec ce masque
à la n oubliez pas qu il y a deux ans
pas plus de deux ans vous avez toute
cette frange de la france oubliée qui a
manifesté très très bruyamment et
pendant longtemps avec les gilet jaune
qui a lancé une première alerte sur et
d'indifférence qui est déportée par ce
pouvoir exécutif à la vie des gens tout
simplement la vie des gens ordinaires
or aujourd'hui on se rend compte que ce
pouvoir-là reproduit très exactement ses
propres faiblesses ses propres
règlements ne voulant pas voir non plus
quelle est la vie des gens ordinaires et
qui est des leurs souffrances au
prétexte de dire qu'il va sauver des
vies il dormait d'autres en péril et je
pense qu'effectivement je moi je mets en
garde depuis longtemps sur la réactivité
de ceux qui n'en peuvent plus et qui ce
qui étouffe sous le sous le poids
notamment d'aider de tous les interdits
en tous les cas c'est pas ce qu'indique
le dernier baromètre du rendez vous
magazine mais à qui on peut vous le
donner en justement en avant première
c'est dans le figaro magazine que l'on
vient de donner à laurent joffrin
emmanuel macron enregistre 3 % de plus
dans sa cote de confiance mais c'est
parce qu'il dit confie alors le pour
répondre elle ne dément pas c'est
exactement ce que répondre à un
internaute qui dit on est toujours en
démocratie parce qu'on peut voter mais
ça ne suffit pas de voter démocratie il
ya deux choses il ya effectivement la
possibilité de choisir ses gouvernants
et donc de les écarter si on n'est pas
content mais il ya une autre
un autre aspect qui est très important
que ryu feuilleton a parfois oublié
c'est l'état de droit c'est à dire qu'on
est dans une architecture
constitutionnelle où il ya des principes
de liberté qui sont chapeautées par la
déclaration des droits de l'homme par
les conventions internationales que nous
avons signés volontairement l échelle
européenne par exemple qui protègent les
libertés publiques et puis ensuite il ya
toute une cascade de droit est
l'instance qui garantissent nos libertés
si ces libertés sont sont bafoués comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
liberté de circuler et de n'entreprendre
liberté de culte tout ça tout ça est
supprimé pour des raisons impérieuses de
nécessité absolue
enfin si ça continue et on sortirait de
la démocratie mais même en pouvant voter
jeu même en voulant ne veut pas entendre
que l'état de droit est précisément met
en cause aujourd'hui la démocratie dire
que dans celles dans la mesure où l'état
de droit oblige les peuples à se
départir de leur souveraineté qui
donnerait la maîtrise des moujahidins
n'est pas tout geek notamment état de
droit aujourd'hui donne aux juges le
pouvoir le pouvoir suprême de dire le
droit alors même que le peuple souverain
la rue elle ne dit pas le droit à la
même place publique l'occasion de faire
les lois au moi je le dis je suis désolé
ce ne sont pas aux juges de faire les
lois se sont aussitôt peuple souverain
ordre des juges et des conventions
devront s'allier roi est adroit
martyrise la démocratie dans la mesure
d'abord d'abord où il ne donne pas les
armes
cette démocratie pour ce pour se
défendre puisque mais vous avez
contradictoires et vous allez pouvoir
vous objecter je vous ferai remarquer je
vous fais remarquer que cet état de
droit
il est réclamé par tous les islamistes
que nous combattons ses terres ce sont
les l'état de droit'' donne les armes à
tous ceux qui nous détenons mais pour se
réclamer des droits de l'homme pour se
réclamer la discrimination pour ce raid
et de réclamer à montmelo teixeira mots
et donc vous jouez avec le feu une fois
de plus vous êtes en pleine me faut
vous êtes en pleine contradiction parce
que vous vous en rêve que macron il a
été élu donc il a le droit de votre
système
il a la souveraineté puisqu'il est élu
il est président de la griffe française
donc leur souverain et donc il a le
droit de confiner tout le monde
ah non il n'a pas le droit il faut qu'il
respecte l'état de droit dans états
devront faire d'importants vous
confondez le droit et l'état de droit à
l'état de droit
l'état de droit dans votre parce que
jeffrey archer l'aîné en vous que je lui
dans précisément mais la hiérarchie des
normes quand elle commencé par leur
hiérarchie commence par cette union
européenne commence par les libertés
publiques je suis désolé mais je crois
justement vous allez les bleus je suis
le premier set européens sur des publics
ciblés qui a défendu le droit de dire
que l'état hébreu prenait qui est un
état de droit supranational qui ce qui
marque un grand mépris des peuples et de
leur souveraineté en aucune façon à la
limite antidémocratique en aucune
manière à le voir l'état de droit
international garantie des libertés
publiques
je me souviens que le que c'est bien
pour sa carrière c'est bien pour ça que
nos libertés vous mais quand des forêts
vous confondez je ne confonds rien
mocratie et souveraineté ce sont deux
choses différentes
la démocratie c'est la loi ne peut pas
seulement par le peuple
oui mais si le popol pour un dictateur
vous serez en dictature faut quatre
copines mais votent alors est ce que
voulait dire je veux dire par là que si
le peuple vote pour un dictateur il va
établir une dictature est en pointe ce
soir il sera plus démocratique
non ce n'est pas plus grave quand elle
pas confiance aux preuves c'est pour ça
qu'il y avait des motivations de ce que
je vous fait la démonstration de ce que
je dis je c'est à dire que vous n'êtes
pas je fais confiance au peuple à
condition qu'ils restent dans la
démocratie
6 il faut pour la ville afev la
démocratie c'est ça la démo non la
mussolini a été populaire donc messieurs
les n'est pas un dictateur bien sûr
michael je suis désolé mais l'allemand
ridicule franchement avant oui je vais
pouvoir légalement vachement hitler
n'est pas un dictateur et vécu qu'est ce
que justement juste pour répondre à ça
c'est pas une objection quand même 40
ans de la part de laurent c'est à dire
si on vote
c'est les gens qui justement
vous vont amoindrir les libertés vont
amoindrir non mais je prends pas ma non
c'est à dire que le peuple la démocratie
nenê bonne n'est valable que quand le
peuple vote dans l'âme dans votre bien
et respecte les libertés publiques ces
libertés publiques elles sont ensuite il
veut faire respecter naturellement mais
ce que je suis en train de vous dire
travers votre état de droit qui est un
état de droit supranational et donc qui
donne toute prérogative au juge
principal et attendons avec la
constitution française
le principe c'est la principale
référence à bercy enfin vous voyez bien
que toutes les délégations aujourd'hui
des grandes institutions françaises ont
été faites auprès de l'union europe
elle est même moins c'est que le conseil
d'état conseil constitutionnel mêmes
principes dont nous mêmes sans donner
plus d'autonomie
surtout pas le parlement parce que le
parlement ne vote plus que des lois qui
sont à 80% inspiré par l'union
européenne est votre état de droit et
donc je vous dis que si vous voulez
retrouver ce qu'est une démocratie
participative une démocratie proche des
gens il faut précisément s'émanciper de
cette étape droit je n'ai rien encore
une fois contre le droit bien entendu je
m'en réclame également autant que vous
mais cette étape droit supranational
d'un état de droit qui est oppressif et
qui en tout cas me semble-t-il est
dangereux pour cette démocratie que nous
voulons retrouver à moins de rester sur
une démocratie confisquée comme vous
semblez vouloir le défendre voulu
manière vous ne voyez pas mais j'ai une
oreillette en fait et moqueries dans mon
oreillette
elle s'habille en fait et j'en suis j'en
suis tout à fait désolé c'est ce que
j'ai les jeudis parle tout le temps j'en
suis désolé de jeu je suis désolé
laurent je pense quand même que
honnêtement on peut dire que le temps de
parole a été équitablement répartis et
surtout entre les toits on a bien
entendu vos points de vue étaient
avérées je plaisante
et ce qui est très rare qu'il fait le
plaisir de nous avons un plateau
ce qui est intéressant dans ce que vous
dites finalement c'est que j'étais
d'accord sur tout il ya des choses
il arrive en irlande et de tous les
invités
il ay on va donner la parole aux
internautes
avant de se quitter parce que c'était
également les objections et les
commentaires sont sont intéressants
également polarisée mais ce qui est
intéressant vous écoutant c'est que vous
êtes d'accord sur le constat c'est que
ya un recul démocratique en france mais
vous vous accuser mutuellement vous
accuser mutuellement vos conceptions
d'être à l'origine de ce recul
démocratique
donc c'était en tous les cas qui était
qui était intéressant de suivre et c'est
fait justement le sel de cette émission
mon peu chacun exprimé son point de vue
parfois on est d'accord parfois on est
d'accord mais en tous les cas c'est
qu'on puisse l'expliquer l'exprimer et
donc le point de vue de kriss kross
c'était de nous dire que ça allait des
restrictions sanitaires allait se
répéter c'est sur arce a peut-être que
là vous êtes d'accord sur un point c'est
peut-être que ces restrictions
sanitaires ne vont pas se répéter au
regard de l'évolution en tous les cas de
du baromètre président seul vous
observerez que la maintenant le
confinement est devenue une pratique
minoritaire vous n'avez plus que quatre
ou cinq pays dans le monde qui conférait
à nouveau et comme il ya une sorte de
mimétisme et tout le monde fait comme
son voisin on peut espérer que le
confinement va se réduire comme une peau
de chagrin
tant mieux alors point d'accord donc au
niveau des invités la démocratie c'est
la liberté d'exprimer son opposition au
pouvoir en place en france cette liberté
totale estimé etienne jx dudit il ne
manque plus que leurs passeports
sanitaires pour avoir un régime
similaire à celui de vichy
ça se vérifie car chardons bleus
nous dit romain nous n'avons plus
confiance dans ces gens qui n'arrêtent
pas de nous mentir et romain ce n'est
pas toujours rose une démocratie par
foyer de la confiance parfois non
effectivement c'est sur ce commentaire
plein de sagesse
effectivement conduit à ce que qu'on va
se quitter en ayant donné le résultat de
la question des réponses par de plus
exactement la question composer avec les
restrictions sanitaires la france est
elle devenue une démocratie défaillante
oui à 61 % estimez-vous et non à 39% et
bien je vous propose de rester plutôt
sur cette thématique puisque dans un
quart d'heure maintenant jean castex et
olivier vers ans vont prendre la parole
pour faire justement le point et donc
une conférence de presse vous pouvez la
suivre en direct sur figaro live donc
vous restez sur la home du figaro si
vous y êtes
et sur la chaîne youtube de figaro life
si vous êtes aussi à très vite sur
figaro live on se retrouve demain même
heure même endroit avec guillaume
enquête
[Musique]